you
whether it's Parma ham or the Airbus
a380 Europe makes things that the rest
of the world wants to buy that's the
nature of trade and it's hugely
important to Europe's economic future
trade policy decisions affect us in many
ways
consumer choice prices quality safety
standards etc trade is also a vital
bridge to other policy objectives not
only commercial but also sustainable
development goals like a better
environment or higher safety standards
and foreign factories
EU trade policy is successful because
it's one of the areas where the Union
speaks with one voice decisions are not
made from an ivory tower citizens
business and other stakeholders can all
participate in the process the European
Commission's trade team has a regular
dialogue with civil society before
during and after deciding on trade
policy or when negotiating agreements
this improves transparency and
accountability
the Commission does not trade goods or
services or favor certain industries
what it does do is set the best possible
legal economic and political environment
so businesses can do that job better
thanks to the single market the EU is a
trade superpower but it needs to up its
game to remain competitive there is a
lot riding on it
30 million EU jobs depend on trade in
fact trade is a powerful weapon against
the economic crisis grip in Europe
selling cars medical instruments
cosmetics turbines brings in much-needed
earnings takes pressure of public
finances and even supports new
inventions technologies and processes
trade is an engine for growth each
additional 1 billion euro of exports
creates some 15,000 more jobs across the
EU per trade faces many hurdles
unnecessary red tape in countries
outside the EU slowing down the flow of
goods different product standards and
the dumping of products at artificially
low prices for example because of
subsidies luxury products but also
technical and industrial inventions
coming from Europe need protecting from
fakes some of our most creative sectors
depend on it and so do consumers whose
safety even health may be put risk it's
tempting to try to protect markets from
competition but that doesn't work in
order to export you also need to import
and trade is the conveyor belt that
links Europe to the new global growth
sensors it's a unique source of
productivity gains for Europe to tap
in the future most worldwide growth is
expected to be generated outside Europe
so today it's critical to engage not
just with major players such as the u.s.
and Japan but also with emerging and
dynamic economies like South Korea India
and Brazil new trade agreements could
boost EU output and create new jobs now
you know why trade matters it's a path
to economic recovery trade policies
shapes the legal economic and political
environment it doesn't favor particular
products sellers or countries the EU is
an important player when it comes to
trade but in a competitive world it must
remain vigilant to make sure others play
by the rules of the game we need to
combat issues such as counterfeiting and
piracy having a dialogue with civil
society and stakeholders is vital
because trade policy affects everyone
[Music]